et du haut de son maître à 90 je vous
demande d'applaudir matthewso
[Applaudissements]
ça fait longtemps qu'ils font ça non
depuis trois ou quatre matchs je trouve
ça bizarre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre fils il a fait un super match il
va rentrer dans quel université aucune
il vient travailler avec nous dans une
entreprise familiale je suis recruteur
si ça vous dit je peux passer quelques
coups de fil et voir s'il y a pas une
place quelque part certaines d'entre
elles ont des bosses d'études
cette chanson comme slogan j'avais
proposé il y aura pas de revanche j'ai
la fin du Rocky c'est un film qui a 40
ans
on peut savoir qui c'est Dany c'est un
plaisir c'est clair que je ne l'aime pas
commence pas être méchante avec elle
elle ne connaît même pas dimanche vous
voulez venir déjeuner dimanche midi
d'accord j'y serai super
Daniel est de Forest Hills on a
travaillé sur une maison là-bas le type
avec la Maserati mais le jaune non merci
ils vont entrer dans cette équipe tout
va changer pour lui et tu voudrais pas
te calmer un peu je suis enthousiaste
sauf que c'est pas un autre décidé Dany
vient de me larguer alors là tu
m'étonnes ta mère est agressive c'est
parce que tu n'aimes pas te voir comme
ça je veux dire
[Musique]
ça va passer faut juste qu'il se remette
en selle et qu'il arrête de penser à
elle
salut Dany s'il est déprimé il passera
jamais les tests est-ce que tu
accepterais de ressortir avec lui pour
trois semaines
[Musique]
c'est de sauver une vie d'humiliation
il peut être tellement stupide
[Musique]
toujours essayer de faire ce que je
pensais être le mieux pour toi tu as
beaucoup de chance tu sais si que
c'était une famille qui t'aime beaucoup
les samares
on l'appelle sticks parce qu'il
ressemblait à un tube de colle on a
failli l'applique coton-tige mais
c'était pas joli et il va encore grandir
cotentige il a fallu que tu lui parles
de ça